[Music]
you're not here to promote the chips
movie it's not coming out for a while
but you are you're in it you're
directing it and you're the perfect guy
because you are not only a muscle car
freak you love motorcycles are you ride
them I do since I was probably 12 I've
been riding them and when I first moved
to LA I was a motorcycle messenger and
so I ride all over the city because we
have such terrible traffic and you are
legally allowed to lane split in
California Drive between the cars yes
now I've noticed when I'm driving they
come so close I mean I'm in my car your
Hummer yeah my few hundred wide I have
together
it runs on rainforest Street I just
chant I the tank koala bear steering
wheel koala bear first steering wheel
Arnel to the backseat but you know I'm
curious about something because well I'm
driving my car to work I noticed that
like a motorcycle will be zipping by it
30 miles an hour because we're all stuck
in traffic and he'll miss my rear view
mirror by what looks like half an inch
they get so close yeah there's not a ton
of room but what the great thing about
it is is you're of Europe very high and
I'm a voyeur so I can see in everybody's
car and I'm naturally a Sheriff at heart
so I'm kind of just checking in on
everybody to see what's what's going on
and I will say the real real number is
one in three people are text messaging
while I pass them on the highway at
least one yes I noticed that I think
we've all noticed that if you're driving
texting yeah and I look over and someone
else's texture texting while you're late
so but the other day I saw something for
the first time in 21 years of lane
splitting in LA I was pulling up to a
light and I glanced to my left and there
was a guy with his phone on his steering
wheel and he was watching a porno at the
stoplight
this really really happened at Gower and
Franklin and I never occurred to me but
yet the technology permits that now you
can watch a porno while you're driving
home and I thought that's crazy but then
I was thinking more about I was like the
guy was probably at work and he couldn't
watch porno there he's presumably going
home to his wife where he will not be
allowed to watch porno
this is his window to catch up on his
programs
he wasn't pleasuring himself he seemed
to just catching up wait so he is
driving the car he's still driving the
car great job driving I have known
complain about his driving and he was
watching like softcore Hartman what's he
watch it was interracial three-way is I
think that's under the umbrella of
hardcore yes yeah yeah that's hardcore
guys do it on planes and no yes you've
seen a guy on an iPad on a plane on a
plane watching porn I just saw the pilot
doing it swear to god I went into the
cabin commercial flight pilot copilot
everybody they were all letting him in
for Conan O'Brien is a key to all
cockpits yeah noise outside the door and
I was like I'm going in there wait
you're jealous I'm jealous of that guy's
confidence though because if I had this
ranch my nostril on a flight I'm like
I'm gonna get something all right
pocket like I'd be so embarrassed yeah
cotton but this guy was just okay yeah
but no it seemed it seemed it like an
aggressive act Oh like it shouldn't take
pride in oh yeah I have to say like
going around LA and just driving around
the country it's it's hard to believe I
don't think there's anything you won't
see someone doing a car now well you
told me yes this is a true story yeah
and I don't want to ruin the punch line
but what did you see driving you were in
like Iowa or something yeah I was in I
was in the Midwest I was doing something
for the show and I've mentioned this
before
but I was in a van with a bunch of
system writers and cameramen and we were
driving along and we were driving along
I think we were near st. Louis and I
looked out the window and we were in
advance that we were above and I saw a
guy driving and he was a big guy
and he was driving with his knees and he
had a giant plate on his lap that had a
full on turkey dinner with all he was
like 50 miles an hour hearing with his
legs and he was he was eating the kind
of media Norman said grace before he
started like really bowed his head his
eyes yeah and he was done and the plate
went aside and then time for Bardo
you